alors oui mon lit n'est pas fait la
bassée bordel la paille en sac par terre
et eau sont faux autant caponi jongler
sur un nuage de sucre et aujourd'hui je
suis devenu ainsi groupe ghi que je
préfère faire ce podcast assis car la
flemme de me lever alors aujourd'hui je
viens d'énoncer un crémant ok c'était
nulle part donc là on en a connu plein
des trucs donc je pense que vous savez
mettre moi il y avait les campeurs ya eu
les yeux et 45 w 2 et touch auteur du
tout temps sur tous les call of qui
veulent concept of veille à rien [ __ ]
en bas d'un avion par exemple il ya
aussi la femme jenna fakim bourg bref ya
vraiment eu plein de trucs nous sauf que
là là une espèce très lettré nous est
apparu je ne sais pas pourquoi il dit ça
tombe sur moi même
maintenant j'ai la gère et c'est génial
car ces individus plutôt bizarre on peut
les reconnaître par trois grands
critères selon moi alors premièrement
ils ont le dos courbé en tant qu une
balade de combler plus qu'une banane
comparaison très nul ceci dit
deuxièmement ils ont relaté de super en
avant mais présente l'avant et
troisièmement ils ont de très grosses
gueules sous les bras très grande forme
et un homme sous les bras cette phrase
et c'est long bref à suivre
j'ai nommé les les jo mais alors
qu'est-ce que son ebit rigueur je me
demande alors l'ubs et rigueur sont en
fait les gens qui ont découvert la
technique du jeu la plus forte depuis
colle à la censure de mes vidéos
alors en fait c'est technique consiste à
poser une betty la bondissante un point
stratégique donc là vont rien d'anormal
même si ça fait quand même déjà un peu
chier mais bon c'est le jeu
je promets je promène succomber là
attention messieurs dames
c'est là qu'est le plus bas tard la
technique les métriques à vous poser un
couteau électrique juste à côté de
l'appétit pour être sûr que tu te la
bouffe bien en pleine gueule
puriste et merde ouais [ __ ] c'est le
truc le plus fort le plus bas des
ruptures agents de to call of duty réuni
fr bfr ben je sais pas quand tu arrives
à ce niveau là tu peux carrément mettre
deux casques pour être sûr d'entendre
bien la musique un super utile
c'est comme mettre 2 quels sont pour
être sûr que ça te legend bien super
utile c'est comme dormir entre deux
oreillers pour être sûr de bien dormir
la levée de mouches
c'est vraiment totalement comme faire ce
à quoi non mais franchement le 1er mai
qui a eu cette idée
il savait bien que s'apprécie tout le
monde alors pourquoi il l'a fait
pourquoi le jeu cyprien
oui aujourd'hui je vais enfin pouvoir me
venger de toutes ces années à souffrir
je vais enfin pouvoir faire chier les
autres comme moi ils m'ont fait chier
oui oui ça va être très bon oui car oui
je suis un gros porc oui je sers à rien
oui je transpire et je paie comme un
cochon bordel oui je suis une grosse
merde et oui c'est pas ta conscience
mais moi qui te parle connard ah merde
enfin bon si toi qui regarde cette vidéo
tu fais tout le temps ces techniques je
t'invite de suite à prendre la direction
de ta salle de bain et la plongée ta
tête dentée toile et de sorte à tutoyer
autrement si toi aussi ceux qui font
cette technique ne font vraiment chier
tu trouve ça vraiment con juste invite à
aimer la vidéo qu'on forme une ligue eq
on irradie totalement les pètes rigueur
de call of duty
oui c'est un rêve tu peux me rejoindre
sur facebook et sur twitter c'est dans
la description et tu peux tu abonnés à
ma chaîne pouvoir de vidéos
à bientôt tout le monde pis ce weekend
be in your eyes prend ignore la peau